okay going back to our top story now and
rebel forces in tigray say they've
seized
a major town in a new offensive in
ethiopia catherine soy joins us now
on the line from humira in the tigray
region catherine
what's the latest on the ground tell us
where you are now
well what we're hearing is that the tds
that the
tigre defense forces are making quicker
that's the southern buddha region we're
told they took a town called karem
it's not clear whether they um are in
full control of ala mata that's what
towns integra we have seen
video very difficult to verify
independently this video because
communication is still
down in many parts of key graph but we
have seen a video of what appears to be
ethiopian forces and amhara special
forces
withdrawing from that
um and this is all in we've been
uh hearing from the degree and
leadership from the
uh different forces who are saying that
they're now priorities in the south
and the west which are still disputed
and which are still being
controlled mostly by amhara forces
they're saying that's their land
and that's what they want to retake
areas like where i am
um in humara before november ahumara and
another town called my
cadre was in control
i wasn't being administered uh by the
tigray and regional force
conflicts many degree and sled these
areas
the areas are being controlled by anhara
forces um
my cadre uh which is about 30 uh 20
kilometers
from whomera where i am is a town where
some of the worst atrocities against
civilians took place in november more
than 600 people came
a while killed most of them laborers um
who have come from different parts of
hamhara um
to have a sesame from firms and mainly
belongs to
uh tigran famous uh amara's here blame
um the the grand fighters for those
killings many of the tigrans
led to sudan uh if you speak to them
that they blame
and it's militia of also you know
forcing out
them out of this region so the tigran
forces saying they're
also heading uh west uh
yes where we are um there's been a lot
of
amharic forces we've been interacting
with but they're also saying that this
land belongs to them
and they will not go without a fight
okay uh catherine we are having a little
bit of trouble
hearing you but just while we've got you
because i know
our communications are intermittent can
you just quickly remind our audience
how this all started
uh yes the communication here is quite
problematic i'm right now using a
setting like phone is the only stable
network that can be used
uh network communication network has
been cut off in most of this area it's
very difficult
to get through to anything but this is a
conflict really that started in early
november
uh federal troops was sent
to tuttigai at the time the government
was saying and that
the grand forces had attacked a military
base
since then prime minister abi ahmed and
his administration also said
that uh the tigran leadership was using
money psyphon from the federal
government to recruit and
train militia to destabilize the rest of
the country
and so there were a danger country
that's why the troops went in
the war was declared over by the
government on the 28th of november
but we are increasingly are seeing
evidence of atrocities that have been
committed
in those areas hundreds of people have
been killed
many millions internally some have fled
up to sudan the u.n says after 400
000 people in tigre are in farming like
conditions 1.8
million of them are on the brink of
farming
a very big problem of humanitarians
accessing some of these people even if
the government has said that it has
opened
it's the airspace integra for
humanitarian flight so that people can
get
help um in areas like where i
am in the west uh that were controlled
uh that while
that the brian uh regional
administration was
um in charge of many times have fled as
well
i'm hard complaining um
of you know atrocities con the tdf the
degree and defense forces so all sides
all communities you talk to are accusing
each other are accusing each other's
forces
of committing these atrocities so the
situation
very dire um in tigray and areas around
tigray
and now with the tdf advancing there's a
lot of concern especially here in the
west
where people uh whether you know the tdf
has been saying that
um it's heading to a lot of nervousness
um with the defense with a special
forces
here saying like i said that they will
not go they don't fight them this land
also belongs to them
it is of course uh you know civilians
getting caught up in this as you say
hey thank you very much uh for that
update there catherine soy
live for us from humira in the tigray
region